what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with the children of the Vault
this story is amazing right Marvel's God
humans so this opens up with martio and
one of the things we talked about in a
previous video for those of you guys who
weren't caught up is the gist of the
children of the vault is that they're
not really humans but they're not really
mutants instead they're beings that are
basically hyper-evolved from a place
called the city in effect time passes
differently so for the human race out in
the real world it's been like I don't
know maybe like 10 years or something
like that since the children of the
Vault first emerged probably less time
than that but for them millions of years
have passed and that's why they're all
so incredibly powerful you're going to
find out just how op these guys are but
martio is one of them and what is going
on is this guy's actually witnessing
a dance party this like a Drummond based
nightclub which sounds amazing but in
the midst of all that cable and Bishop
attack because in the whole fall of X
event there's a lot of moving pieces is
and a lot of stuff all kind of going on
at the same time and while cable and
Bishop have historically been enemies
especially since Messiah complex the
enemy of my enemy is my friend and while
they don't have the ability to take down
orcas in the here and now the reality is
that the children of the Vault represent
a far more clear and present danger
really to everybody on Earth than like
orcas does and again we'll talk a little
bit more about that and it'll become
prevalent as we get through this video
but once martio is taken out cable uses
his body slide technology which I always
love right he's like a guy from the
future right so it's like computer body
slide by three I always love that it's
basically his way to teleport using
technology but talking about this whole
idea of the children of the Vault this
is one of the cool things that goes on
with just how powerful they are because
they just exist in a city that just sits
above Earth and like that's it but these
guys when they first popped up on the
scene instead of just like attacking
humanity and subjugating it they decided
to go the route of actually appearing as
what were basically Heroes we'll talk
about why they did that here in a little
bit but the bigger point is Humanity
ended up embracing them but not really
because Humanity chose to instead the
children of the Vault had kind of
disseminated this virus around the world
that really leads Humanity to perceive
them as Heroes and so what's been going
on is like there's been these staged
attacks against Earth and things are
very murky one of the first things that
happens is like Avengers from Earth 2149
also known as Marvel zombies attack the
Earth
how they got here why they're here we
don't fully know we're never given an
answer they just attack but one of the
things that happens here and I'm
probably going to mispronounce this word
atomo I think is how you pronounce his
name he's one of the children of the
Vault this guy shows up and because he
has the ability to basically restructure
matter on the atomic level he turns like
zombie Captain America into a tree and
like they defeat Marvel Zombies like
that I mean it's crazy when you think
about it right because like Marvel
Zombies conquered whole universes be
these are guys that were able to subdue
and consume Galactus in the Marvel
Zombies universe and they're defeated
with seemingly a wave of Tomo's hand
like that's it following that you end up
having like a rogue faction of the Shia
Empire which is kind of like an Empire
that exists out there in Marvel Comics
instead of being like the Scrolls or the
cree which are like an Empire of a
singular race the Shia is an Empire
composed of multiple races but they have
what are called super Guardians which
isn't really their Imperial Guard but
like these guys are more than enough for
like the X-Men or The Avengers the
children of the Vault overpower these
guys and it's probably the most insane
display of their power Shuma gorath
attacks earth now this is a God just to
give you guys perspective here shumo
gorath is a guy with a level of power
that his Empire spans entire universes
right this guy's a multiversal being he
exists in the spaces between universes
but this guy's subjugated and conquered
entire universes the children of the
Vault take this guy out it's nuts like
it's crazy the level of power that
the cable and the reason why is because
he
to the mindscape now for those of you
guys who have been reading X-Men comics
for a long time specifically since Grant
Morrison's run this is going to remind
you of the silent issue when Emma Frost
and Jean Gray went into the mind of
Cassandra Nova to basically free Charles
Xavier that's what this is right like
literally cable goes into the mindscape
of martio and what you end up having
here is this giant Citadel now what was
established in Grant Morrison's new
X-Men 121 with the silent issue is that
when it comes to a person with basically
capable psychic conditioning meaning
that they have information or something
like that but basically their mind's
been conditioned to allow them to
withstand telepathy even if they can't
necessarily outright overcome it that
secrets and things like that are locked
inside of a vault that's what this giant
Tower is right it holds secrets that
cable is looking for exactly what that
is we'll find out in time but the fact
that like Grant Morrison's new X-Men
established that only telepaths of the
highest order Jean Gray Emma Frost could
actually enter into the mindscape like
this and then overtake this kind of
tower security really gives us another
illustration of the fact that Cable's
just that powerful and for the most part
we know it's just good to know that they
haven't de-powered him in recent years
and made him weaker but what he's doing
here is he's like interrogating martio
and the conversation is amazing because
initially cable kind of like speaks
Spanish to him and the response of
martillo is like Spanish English Latin
curcumen all your languages are dead
languages to us because we're we're like
a million years ahead of you right in
terms of our Evolution and everything
we've learned now one of the things that
I do want to specify here is that
there's a difference between being hyper
evolved inside of a city where time
passes differently being evolved by like
a million years and actually coming from
a million years in the future two
distinctly different things cable
basically has the upper hand here
because cable is tangibly from the
future the children of the vaults were
just in a place where time passes
differently right things just move
faster inside the city itself but the
reality here is the real world has not
moved forward by a million years and
that's where they come from it doesn't
work that way but for cable himself
going inside the mind of martillo as
he's interrogating him the conversation
is amazing because Cable says I was
there the first time you crazy kids
crawled out of your hidey hole got
yourself some new clothes and a new name
but I don't think much has changed still
trying to conquer the world and the
response of martio is we cannot be
judged for that it was a million years
and a thousand lifetimes ago and that's
why cable responds and saying not to us
and he says tell me about the message
martio I know it's some kind of semiotic
virus what exactly does it do and the
response of martio here is it's better
to not question the message it is better
to simply just accept it now one of the
cool really kind of relationships or
similarities here between like Martino
is with a guy named William Striker
because while William Striker is
technically staunchly anti-mutant he's a
religious fanatic there was a story
where he blew up a busload of kids I
mean the guy does some crazy stuff the
reality here is that in a lot of ways
it's very similar the message of William
Striker right mutants are an Abomination
mutants need to be eradicated because
God doesn't want mutants to exist the
response of martio except our message it
is the way our belief is inevitable
we're just that far beyond you that kind
of a thing whether they're appealing to
their own evolutionary processes or
William Striker's appealing to God at
the end of the day they're still
appealing to this concept of some
immutable indestructible Force out there
so the response of cable is simply
saying you're trying to pacify us is
that it and then what when do you finish
the job and the response of martillo is
lonely little mutant so obvious you may
be from their future but to me you're
still Stone Age I see you cable digging
through my thoughts like a dog and so
what martio does is he kind of activates
this sort of defense system inside his
own mind where like a giant statue shows
up now this statue is wielding a
gigantic Hammer because that's the
weapon of martio a gigantic Hammer but
he says I empathize with you you know
really in a sense I am on your side you
believed you were building a future for
yourselves and that future was taken
from you of course he's referencing all
the mutants consolidating on the island
of cocoa and trying to live their lives
in peace with their own government and
so on and he says but understand it was
never your future 50 of us of us the
children of the Vault could exterminate
the human race in one day many of our
people wanted to and be done with it but
some of us believe we have evolved past
all of that the message is the new way a
better way and so what you do is you
switch over to Bishop because the
question has to be asked if cable is
interrogating martillo what's Bishop
ship doing what Bishop's actually doing
is gathering arms and Armament now one
of the things that happens here is we
get this kind of expansion or maybe a
little bit of an explanation that sort
of adds to the nature of Bishop's powers
and the reason why I say that is the
power of Bishop is to absorb energy and
then to re-channel that energy back and
it can be virtually any form of energy
right a physical attack somebody
shooting him with an energy blast a gun
it doesn't really matter right so long
as it doesn't destroy his physical form
and he's able to let that energy off so
he doesn't explode he can just kind of
fire it off as a concussive blast one of
the things that's going on here at what
used to be the old Xavier Institute for
gifted youngsters where the X-Men used
to reside that when Bishop gets in
they're basically emitting these kind of
energy pulses and what these do is they
almost act as a kind of sonar right like
if it picks up Movement Like a human
being moving around there who's not
supposed to be there that it'll Sound
the Alarm what Bishop does is he absorbs
herbs these energy Fields but he has to
be very very very nuanced about it right
we're literally told absorb too much of
the energy from these energy fields and
you're a walking black hole in effect
anybody who's watching these energy
fields and how they're interacting and
so on would see that like as he's making
his way through this area suddenly like
these energy Fields seemingly shut down
and then reactivate and somebody's gonna
say okay something's going on there we
need to go investigate but he says if
you absorb too little you basically
start setting off alarms so he has to be
very very particular in terms of exactly
how much energy he absorbs and how long
he absorbs it for but the reality of
this is that because he's able to make
his way onto the grounds and he's able
to access a kind of back door into the
basement of The Institute when he gets
in there it's just a boatload of weapons
right virtually every gun that you can
possibly imagine now at that point we
switch over to the real motivation of
the children of the Vault and why all
this is happening in the first place so
what we end up finding out is that
because this kind of virus in the brain
that drives Humanity to see the children
of the vault as saviors has basically
reached every corner of the world even
the United Nations grants the city of
the children of the Vault its own
autonomy right like we recognize this
place as a Sovereign Nation right
official sanction so the United Nations
is bending the knee to the children of
the Vault and that's when you get this
really cool conversation between
Seraphina and the captain and they have
two distinctly different perspectives on
how things should have been done the
captain kind of basically follows That
Old Guard mentality Wipe Out the
entirety of the human population cleanse
the Earth call everyone and then the
children will inherit the planet
Seraphina follows the philosophy of
saying if we do that then basically
it'll instigate war and if Humanity has
proven itself to do anything over the
years especially when it comes to the
Avengers or the X-Men or any number of
teams out there we won't be able to
destroy them all some will go
underground and when they go underground
they'll Marshal their forces they'll
build they'll retaliate and it's
entirely possible that they could kill
us right so the best thing that we could
possibly do here if what we really want
to do is conquer the human race was not
to appear as Warriors not to appear as
conquerors but to use the Trojan Horse
to show up here right to throw a virus
out there and then Humanity sees the
children of the Vault when they arrive
as being the Savior type beings the
Marvel Zombies Universe attacking the
super Guardians shumagorath it's
entirely possible none of that actually
happened that none of it's real that is
all in illusion created by the children
of the ball using their knowledge of the
various threats that Earth has seen its
superheroes facing off against and by
defeating those threats that humans are
in some capacity aware of their quote
unquote protecting the world from any
threats that exist out there they play
the the role as Heroes now the reality
is seraphina's strategy is the best
strategy if what you're looking to do is
to go into any particular territory and
conquer the existing race there while
also take that territory for yourself
you don't want to start an outright War
because if you do that it's going to lay
waste to territories buildings and
cities and all that kind of stuff and
then you're gonna have to have like the
whole rebuilding process the smarter
thing to do is to go in subjugate the
populace get the populace to see you as
a hero and then slowly start eliminating
them that way it's diabolical
in every sense of the word but it is the
smartest thing to do and so they have
this kind of philosophical argument
right where the captain even goes so far
as to say look at Humanity right like we
could lead them into a better future but
the reality is if they wanted to be led
into a better future they wouldn't
resist superheroes they wouldn't stand
against the superhero population more so
than that they would have led themselves
to a better future the fact that
Humanity is so regressive and the fact
that it spends so much time and the fact
that it's so unwilling to move forward
that it has to be drug Kicking and
Screaming means the only thing that we
should be doing is Conquering them right
Humanity only understands strength it
only understands War we know that
because Humanity's entire history is
nothing but strength and War right give
them what they give others and they in
turn will be subjugated by us and
they'll stop asking questions again it's
just this kind of philosophical debate
going back and forth there's not
necessarily a wrong answer here although
I think seraphina's approach is the most
logical one and the smartest one but
switching back to Cable in the mindscape
you basically have again this statement
by martial where he says become the
Future these are More Than Just Words
the message is not a virus it is only an
idea one so clear and so self-evidently
true it transforms first in mind then in
body those who will survive will think
and feel and fly as we do they will be
true children at a genetic level the
rest those who can't change or won't
change there will be no place for them
and cable asked the question and how
many is that how many do not make it
into your future and the response of
martio is we estimate that less than one
percent of humanity Will Survive the
change less than one percent will make
it
99.9 or more will be wiped out they will
die and he even says mutants projected
the human race would be gone in 20 years
we think we have it down to about six
months and he even says you cannot stop
us we have been preparing since we
escaped your mutant dream prison 200
years have passed for us inside the
Vault and over the course of that 200
years we've been sharpening our knives
200 years raising our hammers you cannot
stop us we are the future and in that
moment Cable in the mind of martio
cracks The Vault he ends up finding like
just this little ballerina type person
inside of it but then it's really cool
because literally martillo says they're
here my people have come it is finished
for you the response of cable is the
best thing ever and it's the most cable
response that there ever was right he's
like finished you didn't think I'd
actually be here in person did you I
could catch something check under your
seat and under the seat is a nuclear
bomb the thing detonates and it destroys
martillo on the spot cable was actually
with Bishop when Bishop was going
through and grabbing all these arms and
Armament and I gotta tell you guys man
I'm not gonna lie cable looks like he
did in the old Rob liefeld days poor Rob
liefeld that poor bastard guy couldn't
draw a fee to save his life but that
dude loved pockets and the way he made
cable look in those old school Comics
was amazing with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you guys need to get caught up on
follow Vex make sure you click this link
to the playlist and I will catch you all
later peace